lu attribué par le conseil
d'administration de 4 million d'euros
pour avoir fait soi-disant une bonne
vente c'est plus que ça représente plus
que l'ensemble des augmentations du
personnel à transport France qui
représente 9000 salariés quel avenir
pour les portiques mis en place dans le
cadre du projet ecotax le ministère en
charge des transports souhaitent les
démonter mais RIC stromman le président
du conseil départemental du Ain propose
lui que ces dispositifs puissent être
maintenu en Alsace dans le cadre d'un
dispositif expérimental de substitution
qui serait donc propre à notre région ne
nous précipitons pas en Alsace sur ce
sujet mon idée c'est qu'on passe une
convention avec le Tol système le
système allemand qui fonctionne
apparemment à la satisfaction de tous
les usagers et que par voie d'amenant
avec les collectivités alsacien on
puisse étendre la taxe allemande vers
vers les opérateurs vers le territoire
alsacien et ce qui permettra à l'Alsace
de
bénéficier de recettes financières et
fiscales supplémentaires pour
l'aménagement de nos routes
départementales mais également les
routes nationales qui en ont bien besoin
marieise le branchu éta en
Alsace